hello everyone um welcome my name is
sanjay sarma i'm professor of mechanical
engineering at mit
and i'm also the vice president for open
learning what a wonderful gathering this
is this is really siblings and cousins
and brothers and sisters
in the open education movement
knowledge is like oxygen
i hope no one figures out
how to charge for oxygen i hope we
figure out a way in which we never
charge for knowledge it should be like
the air we should breathe
um we are at a very interesting point in
time mit faculty speaking for my own
colleagues have an opportunity to learn
from senior leaders at hbcus
who are promoting educational equity by
spearheading oer
open education resources within their
institutions
and we're looking at mit to include
culturally relevant materials in our own
courses
this effort is an invaluable resource
for discovering more inclusive
a more inclusive canon of oer
now the hope really is that my
colleagues adapt these oer materials
created by hbcus and colleagues in our
own courses here
and then we share them back uh with the
world through
opencourseware
and so this way we can collectively
promote educational equity not only
within our mit community
but in the nation and perhaps the world
the question really for us today is
uh how can we do this today uh how can
we do this together and this is just the
first conversation how do we establish a
metabolism
of open educational resources especially
around equity
and around
in this particular case right now for
our discussion around
materials that are culturally uh
relevant
so i would like to particularly thank um
two colleagues robbie melton and jerry
hanlon for doing this great event and
and the amazing panelists and i welcome
you to this and with that i'll hand off
to my friend and colleague kurt
newton from mit
thank you sanjay just a couple of
housekeeping notes before we dive in
um we're going to try to use the chat
collectively uh in the spirit of
conversation as we're going please enter
your questions in the chat and i'll
encourage uh our our presenters here to
uh to engage and feel free to answer
directly as we're going
and as we get into the q a at the end um
you know um just if you don't want to
appear in the video uh suggest you keep
your video turned off
um i'd like to thank um
along with um all of uh all of our
participants here today who have joined
us also uh thank the hewlett foundation
for facilitating this introduction uh
between uh mit open learning and these
hbcu leaders and to our colleagues
across the open 2030 working group for
the inspiration over the past couple of
years and again just reiterating uh
sanjay's closing remark we hope that
this is the first what will be many many
ongoing conversations
and with that
i'd like to hand over to
dr robbie melton
welcome everyone i'm robbie melton and
today
we are going
to help history in the making
again i'm robbie melton on behalf of the
historically black colleges and
university and tennessee state
university we are here to share our
passion our purpose but today
we all colleagues
will make history
i already had a presentation for you and
you'll see by my slides but i'm going to
go off script on purpose
ladies and gentlemen on behalf of all
educators in the world
we
all
are in a war
today
we're not going to just talk about open
education we're going to do something
about it on behalf of the people of
ukraine who are now leaving their homes
leaving their schools
leaving
their history
today
we're going to share with you why we
have the cultural collection
we are here to demonstrate all of us
what we can do
with the mighty tool of technology
today as we present and share with you
the purpose of a cultural collection
not only for the hbcu
but for the world
we dedicate this presentation to those
diversity
inclusive
all of those words that we hear today
we're going to do something about it so
i have my team already in the chat
and
as we go through this presentation this
is what we're going to do
we are going to capture
the culture of the ukraine as they try
to take it away
with open education which means open to
everyone i'm going to have you because
you know how to multitask
while you're at your computer
i'm going to have you
to find
on the internet
history famous people
whatever about the ukraine and you're
going to put that url
in the chat
my team
will capture that url highlighting
the ukraine and their contribution to
education
because by the time
you
wake up tomorrow morning we will have a
cultural collection on behalf
of the ukraine people they will not lose
their history nor their education
all of you should celebrate
on behalf of the hewlett foundation why
a cultural collection is so vital to
open education
and with that we are all
now responsible
because we have the tool of technology
to help underserved population and we're
going to do it today
so with that everyone i'm going to go
through my presentation but you have
homework to do
while you're at that computer
listening
i need for you to start searching
get on google's get on those search
engine and find information
about the ukraine
so that we can put it in a special
collection that's what we can do
together
so with that i will start my
presentation
but
we are here again for a purpose the
purpose of the cultural collection for
the hbcu the same as every other
underserved population
it is to bring to the world our
contribution our achievement and to
share share share
so with that on behalf of the
106 hbcu
sisters we come to you
with a curation
of
our history our achievement
how about our distinguished faculty
members
so
as we roll this away
we again can change this whole world and
we can do something about it so with
that again the next slide will share
with you
our
cultural collection
and our
underlying
purpose right now everybody
students cannot learn from books they
can't afford
we all know that
and unfortunately in our day people are
trying to restrict books
they're trying to destroy books
we together all 75 of us
can
make sure
we have access to
education and books next slide please
so with that everyone you know
the cost of textbooks
here's some old numbers because
inflation already jumped up the price of
textbooks
right now the average cost twelve
hundred dollars you might think wow
that's okay no it's not okay
again students cannot learn from books
they cannot afford next slide
so with that let me just share with you
the impact of textbook costs on students
again you see the statistics some take
fewer courses
some don't even register for a pacific
course or how about you just drop out or
withdraw
here's the one that you should center on
earn a poor grade because i could not
afford to buy the textbook
fail of course because i couldn't afford
or guess what everyone
you don't purchase the required book at
all
open education that's what we are here
for
but within open education next slide
please
we missed a little component
and so
we were able to conduct
hot off the press
a faculty and student survey report
and okay you all know
we know that we need to inform more we
need to contribute more but guess what
else we found
we found next slide that
we were missing a whole component
of cultural
selection
our students our faculty our communities
kept saying
thank you for open education thank you
for a free textbook thank you for
affordable learning solution however
next slide please
you will see that they also found
that they didn't
find culturally relevant materials look
at the numbers
this should say something
again
we have
in our hands the tools
knowledge to do something about this so
on behalf of the hbcus
guess what
we formed through a partnership with
merlot merlot.org all right everybody
put merlot.org right there
because jerry hanley who you're going to
hear in a few minutes stepped up
with his open education portal to say
let's do something about it so that's
why you are here we're here to share
with you not what we're going to do
quote unquote
we're here to share with you what we
have completed the next slide we'll
share with you
on behalf of the support
from the william and flora hewlett
foundation and yes i'm going to call out
angela
yes angela b barger
she
listen
the hewlett foundation said
there's a need
and ladies and gentlemen i'm here to
present to you
with a panel a distinguished panel and
now with the partnership of mit
that we are able to curate
highlight showcase and give you just a
little taste
of our hbcu
cultural collection next slide thank you
so on behalf again of the historically
black college and university you must be
asking again
the purpose the purpose
you're going to learn something today
number two you're gonna do something
today number three on behalf of the
hbcus
we
celebrate all
all cultures next slide
so i am pleased to share with you i need
a drum roll
that our cultural collection
includes not just general information
biography black history month hbcu
history but
we are able to address diversity equity
inclusiveness
all within this open education portal
again access from all over the world
that anytime any place any type of
whatever that can hook up to that
internet
you have this rich resource right there
at
your words so with that with our
cultural collection next slide please
i'm here to highlight again
our need and guess what they're going to
put it in the chat right now because you
can go to it right now
and again
just think you are logged on only eight
minutes ago and now
you have the richness of the hbcu
community
right there for you next slide please
so
on
a partnership that's what all of this
about
kurt and mit we're talking relationship
partnership sharing
where on behalf of the national museum
of african american history and culture
we already have
curated for you where you don't even
have to search and dig and all that deep
diving no we want it up front and center
we have
curated for you on behalf of the hbcs
anything you can think of regarding our
history and contribution
and
next slide please and as you view this
we now want to talk about how do we get
the word out how do we expand everyone
we have a model
so it's not just oh we're going to
inform or we're going to be strategic
we are piloting what we call our oer
campus implementation we know it has to
start and be supported from the top but
we have to talk about sustainability we
have to talk about how do you engage
your faculty and beyond that we're
talking community here we're talking the
world how do we get it out so we include
as you see an adoption plan that starts
with the college
who
everyone
we're talking about the college chair
to the faculty and the next slide we'll
share with you
we thought if we could have two or more
from a department to engage to create to
remix to re distribute
all of oer materials
we would see
impact and ladies and gentlemen i'm here
to share with you we have impact
that's why we're here today to share so
you see our deployment findings how we
started with campus awareness faculty
training course redesign and pilot as
well as research next slide
and
now i'm here to share with you in a few
minutes you're going to hear from our
regional hubs we know
that
touch and technology
must go together our regional hubs are
able to touch other affiliates within
our hbcu family and boy wait do you see
in a few seconds what they have to share
so with that next slide
again with the help of merlot
www.merlot.org yes you can drink it too
i want you to know on behalf of higher
education not just for the hbcus
but for the whole world we are global
we have communities in all disciplines
and we have peer review but jerry hanley
i would like to bring him on but again
you should be searching we're going to
do something about that cultural
collection for the ukraine jerry hanley
uh hello everyone jerry hanley here from
merlot skills commons and
california state university long beach
and i just want to say it's just a
pleasure to be a partner with so many of
the friends here within our hbcus and
just going to say a few quick things
about what merlot brings to the table
in partnership
to really pursue the passions and the
purposes that robbie has outlined
so the first thing i think one of the
thing is as robbie laid out you need an
institutional strategy
in order to really bring a community of
people together because only together
can you really solve some of these very
challenging problems and when we bring
the affordable learning solutions so we
begin with what is the learning
solutions that will enable our students
to be successful and our faculty to
teach their discipline
then how do you make it affordable and
that has been a critical element and for
over 10 years we've merlot has been
working on this and with a grateful
support for the from the hewlett
foundation over the many years of doing
this we begin to customize these
programs to fit into
the unique campus cultures of each
institution
and i think as robbie pointed out around
building the collection well this is
where the technical infrastructure where
robbie and and her colleagues at the
hbcu say
jerry we need a bookshelf for black
history month
well it's easy to put that metadata
structure in there create customized
portals and within the last six months
over 500 new materials were created and
contributed into the merlot's africana
culture collection
and then finally
an important capability in order for
each of us
to create
inclusive strategies of content and
pedagogical strategies that you have to
enable the remixing and the revising of
content
so it can be aligned with your local
needs of your students and your faculty
and your community and that's one of the
power of oer is that it's in enabling
that process and by working with both
open source applications and commercial
providers to enable that remixing and
revising is going to be very important
in order to close the equity gaps that
are so pervasive in education both in
the u.s and around the world
so with that i'm going to pass it off
back to
the tennessee state university national
hub who has been just amazing in their
leadership so
back to you
and i welcome um the tennessee hub the
tennessee hub
serving
as that hub for the
hbcus with the cultural collection i
bring on the tennessee hub
hello everyone and i am dr deborah
chisholm executive director at tennessee
state university for oer i also have
with me my two colleagues dr ampadu and
dr hassell who will introduce themselves
after i finish presenting next slide
please
tsu hbcu
affordable learning solutions
the tennessee state university is the
national hub
coordination of hbcu oer training
hbcu oer faculty and student survey
coordination of hbcu oer webinars hbcu
oerl library resources coordination of
hbcu
oer pilots and coordination of the
cultural collection as well next slide
please
did you know at tennessee state
university we have 33 oer pilot faculty
members we also have 14 departments two
faculty members per department and 17
oer campus webinars for 2021
next slide please
our impact at tennessee state university
a student savings of 81 000
this past fall semester with just 33
faculty members using the free oer
materials
and now i'll pass it to dr ampadu dr
ampadu
thank you so much dr chisholm hello my
name is dr ampadu moss i am the director
of hbcu oer here at the great tennessee
state university we help
coordinate hvcu oer webinars hbcu oer
surveys
academic communities and oer faculty
outreach next slide
when we help our faculty members we are
able to allow them to come to a amazing
portal where they can go to the tsu
excel for ed and find oer materials we
can showcase our faculty members we can
have academic communities we'll have
accessibility for the faculty members
and their students we find other oer
resources that are um that are already
available with different strategies and
tips they can use in the classroom and
then of course the hbcu pilots that we
do every semester
now with one of our pilot studies our
faculty members their responses for
2021. they stated that there is a need
for training on the use of the creative
commons licensing that there is an
increase there needs to be an increase
of cultural collections there is a need
for updated discipline related over your
materials and there is a need for
faculty training regarding the creation
of oer materials
so after we gathered that information we
said okay what are we going to do we
decided to have
webinars every tuesday at 3 30 where the
faculty members can go ahead and click
on so we can help fill the gap and fill
all the needs of the faculty members
and now i'm going to go ahead and pass
it on to the amazing dr robert hassell
thank you dr embardo i am dr robert
hassell tsu learning support staff here
for riding and the oer student success
consultant coordinator here at tennessee
state university next slide please
we decided to call all the students and
we got feedback from surveys and they
gave us the following recommendations
concerning our student population that
there was a need for oer awareness and
benefits among the students
and there is a need for on hand
workshops
and the need for culturally related
materials and this response indicated
that there was a need for more
information in their particular
disciplines of study next slide please
one of the most phenomenal things we
were able to do here at tennessee state
university is create an open educational
resource student success coach at tsu
we also established our oer bibliography
of tsu current students staff and alumni
which we are proud to give you a glimpse
of today
here's a recap of our amazing
alumni here in the land of golden
sunshine at tennessee state university
dr glen debastin's bassin-glover who is
our eighth institutional president and
the first woman president she is the
international president of alpha kappa
alpha sorority incorporated
next we have the amazing ed temple and
ed temple has strove so hard to get 43
tsu olympians to the olympics every year
oprah winfrey is a talk show host
philanthropist
and notable alumni of tennessee state
university she is best known for the
oprah winfrey show broadcasting chicago
which is the highest rated television
program of its kind in history
and then we have the great jesse russell
senior who if you pick up your phones
and you see that little triangle that
says data he created that he patented
that and he was also the first african
american to be hired by a t
thank you so much
now we'll pass along to our partners
and yes and i have my phone right here
so again audience this to give you a
little taste of the purpose of the
cultural collection so we'll start with
our partner institution central state on
behalf of president thomas and
miss dr arlene mcswain i'm here to share
with you on their behalf with open
education resources and this support
i'm pleased to share with you
they have not only courses but they have
certificate and degree program
using
100 percent o e r
ladies and gentlemen that means that
those students are ready the first day
first minute of class because what
open education resources already in hand
so again that central state as
established by dr arletha mcswain
our next partner coming up i would like
to introduce to you
will be
southern university at shreveport it is
my pleasure to introduce to you dr
veronica mcishen and she's going to let
you know how they pulled the whole
department together take it away
greetings from southern university at
shreveport under the leadership of dr
penning our interim chancellor and dr
barry hester our interim vice chancellor
this is a great opportunity to share
some information with you i would like
to share some info some history briefly
with you
i started helping faculty members find
open educational resources in 1999
before it was actually named at wally
college in marshall texas in 2012 we
developed our online courses used in oer
under the leadership of dr kim long i
then moved to southern university at
shreveport in 2014
and started introducing oer to the
campus at first i received a lot of
pushback from the faculty however i
developed a strategy to work with those
that worked with me
and constantly encouraged other faculty
members to participate
dr wan diwali recommended that we focus
on developing general education courses
after developing the general education
courses in
oer using oer in 2016
this automatically made most of our
programs oer hybrid because we are a
two-year community college
in
2017 we developed our session 100 online
program in criminal justice using oer
the criminal justice faculty members
decided to use the oer course materials
in our face-to-face classes all criminal
justice students start the first day of
class with their course material ready
to be used at no cost
moving fast
fast forward into the present this
opportunity allows southern university
at shreveport to continue developing the
core courses to build 100 percent online
program using open educational resources
we are currently developing
a 100 percent online program in in
psychology
and we are developing courses for our
non-science
of students in biology and chemistry
our faculty members that are currently
working in the project
they are called the design team we meet
every monday for about 30 minutes and
we're preparing to present this
information to our entire faculty
teaching sharing with them lessons
learned
so again we would like to thank dr
robbie melton dr jerry hanley and their
team for providing training and support
for our campus so that we can continue
developing 100 online programs using
free resources thank you for this
opportunity
and of course we thank you so much and
again did you hear that criminal justice
totally online psychology and again
anywhere anyplace anywhere in the world
you can tap in on those resources ready
for you right now i'm pleased now to
share with you a friend
john jock
again from edward waters university and
he's going to give you a perspective
globally where we are able to make a
difference
to a country in need of open education
resources
greetings greetings everyone i cannot
even begin to tell you how happy i am to
be here this morning or afternoon
representing eduardo's university on
this wonderful open education journey i
want to thank our two affiliate
institutions lawson state community
college and denmark technical college
for joining with us in this effort our
main priority is to make a college
education attainable and accessible to
as many
students as possible through oer because
we believe that education is a
fundamental human right therefore we
should not allow anything to hinder the
success of anyone or any group in their
pursuit of an education and that's why
we're here today
edward waters university
is distinctively florida's oldest
independent institution of higher
education higher learning as well as the
state's first institution established
for the education of african americans
from the beginning ewu was faced with
both abject poverty and widespread
illiteracy among its constituents which
explains why even today ninety percent
of our students are peregrine recipients
thus
what dr robbie melton
and dr jerry kinley are doing for the
hbcu community as they facilitate access
for our students to open uh educational
resources is beyond miraculous
this is why i am so excited to report
that our first oer workshop at ewu which
was held over a week ago was attended by
about 90 of the faculty pretty
remarkable
so our local als team is now motivated
to gather data to add to the merlot's
cultural collection because we do have a
story to tell
we are also looking to extend this
opportunity to developing countries such
as haiti where higher education is
literally a luxury i should know because
i'm originally from there i remember
when i was in high school
i had to copy
textbook chapters by hand
to prepare
for an exam and that was on a regular
basis
so
i don't have to tell you that
this
opportunity
would be like manner from heaven for the
haitian students
thank you abby thank you jerry
so what we're doing on our campus is is
making sure that everybody understand my
responsibility personally is to
make convey this key message to show our
students that we care we care for their
success we care for their education and
that's why
i am so excited about the level of
involvement of my faculty and and the
leadership at the university so we all
ready we are equipped and we are
thankful for being on this journey thank
you everybody
and we thank you and again
you see the purpose for cultural
collection you see the purpose of open
education resources and yes
every day we upload we search just like
you all are doing now for the ukraine so
that we can have a cultural collection
built at this time it is my pleasure to
bring on bethune cookman
and you will see for their graduate
program the impact of open education
resources
good afternoon
maintaining the spirit of our founder dr
mary mcleod bethune
bethune cookman university allows
collaboration to bolster the infusion of
open education resources in
undergraduate and graduate courses
not only on our campus in daytona beach
florida but with external partners
simmons college of kentucky
and florida a m university
currently 12 graduate faculty members
are revamping courses to feature
open education resources or function as
an oer only course
next slide please
a few strategies undertaken by us to
propel forward include converting all
general education courses to open
education resources
persuading six of eight graduate
programs and all graduate programs
offering online degrees and certificates
to include oer or fully convert courses
to oer
currently there are more than 50 faculty
members
who have merlot
accounts
we continue to recruit faculty
across our partner universities
sharing recordings that highlight
discipline specific oer with faculty
is another proven strategy
and finally being recognized for our oer
efforts
have all assisted in moving us forward
thank you
ladies and gentlemen did you hear that
the general ed core
all open education
graduate programs now you can see
together how we can share
so with that i bring you
morehouse college
take it away dr earl lewis
good afternoon and greetings colleagues
i bring you greetings on behalf of dr
david a thomas the 12th president of
morehouse college dr kendrick brown
provost and senior vice president for
academic affairs and dr clarissa merrick
harris the chair of the division of
humanities
this is how our oer program is anchored
at morehouse college and moving forward
with our partners claflin university
clark atlanta university and our newest
partner livingston college
i like dr mceecrin began using open
educational resources as a response to
having culturally relevant pedagogical
content as a part of my own learning and
then again when i became a member of the
faculty at florida memorial university
today at morehouse college next slide
please our key mission
our key message is mission driven
the mission of morehouse college is to
develop men with disciplined minds who
will lead lives of leadership and
service with special responsibility for
advancing knowledge of black life
history and culture
so how are we doing oer
at morehouse college
we are engaging it in teaching and
learning
faculty development and service learning
let me share a few examples
as a part of the teaching and learning
100
of the africana studies faculty
and affiliated faculty within the
departments of english history
journalism religion and philosophy
cinema television and emerging media
music mathematics computer science
business and economics are using
affordable learning solutions
as a part of our fall 2021 semester we
offered 35 sections of our fye general
education courses
15 sections of those courses the
african-american experience
and
introduction to africana studies
representing approximately 45 percent of
the fye courses
were all oer
with this in mind we estimate that we
had a savings of
and
2
dollars per course
this resulted in approximately thirty
three thousand seven hundred and fifty
dollars worth of savings for students
during the fall semester who were
enrolled in our general education
courses the african-american experience
but students what is the impact
what i am learning
both anecdotally and through the data is
that students remain surprised that
their learning can begin before the
first day of class by having access to
open educational resources and tools to
support their learning
within our partnerships
as we are moving with the faculty
development piece we have engaged a
partner through a healing paradigm which
is a local wellness and psychological
services center and dr kevin coakley at
ut austin who created an open source
culturally relevant texts
called making black lives matter
confronting anti-bias and racism
we're using that text as a foundational
resource for facilitating understanding
as well as providing knowledge it is
well researched open source and includes
the voices of both undergraduate and
graduate students
as a part of our oer commitment to
service learning our bonner office for
community service
engages oer through the use of our apple
initiative
they engage coding and creativity and
all of the apple learning resources as a
part of their service learning in a one
credit lab as well as a three credit
hour course
they all become apple teachers improve
their technology skills learn how to
prototype apps and do this service in
our communities
we are excited to continue this
partnership as we move forward and our
office of academic affairs is providing
fiscal resources to support faculty
research course redesign and student
internships to conduct research
utilizing als
so please join us in visiting the hbcu
cultural collection to learn more about
morehouse and our esteemed
alumni
thank you so much for being here today
and we thank you so much and again
everyone everyone we only got a few more
minutes okay
remember
all that we have shared is available for
you
right now
so again they're going to enter the url
for the hbcu affordable learning
solution
and
instantly you have all that we have
we're going to conclude with our network
across all of our 106
sister
hbcus
take it away dr
jacqueline good afternoon
my name is dr jacqueline mcgee
i am the library director here at
arkansas about this college in little
rock um but i also consider myself as
part as the of the tsu the tennessee
state u the tennessee state university
family
and part of the um hbcu oer librarian
curator um one of the my i usually help
coordinate strategies and tips and find
curated resources um for all of the hbcu
librarians
to help keep oer systems readily
available to your faculty to your
students on all of the hbcu campuses and
throughout the year
the best way i found doing this is by
consistently staying in discussion with
other fellow librarians and finding out
what their strengths and
threats
opportunities and weaknesses are on all
the campuses and using that as a road
map to help other librarians
troubleshoot issues they may be having
on their campuses
but several of your libraries have
already started to receive information
from me on a monthly basis and like dr
melton said like she spoke about we are
all here to help distribute information
to one another um and we just discussed
the oer cultural collection which
provides a wealth of information um from
exploring african american and black
study collection and murloc to exploring
free
free open educational resources related
to african topics
exploring oer on diversity equity and
inclusiveness
but our initial priority
is to build the oer cultural collection
so each month there are several of us
who actually post items and information
like you've just heard
to the site um and dr melton the team
and i we're all interested in what each
of our schools are doing um there's a
lot of information that need to be
shared and this is another way that it's
possible for us to do so so uploading
information to that website is the key
it's visible to not just the hbcus but
to the world
and i try to recognize our strengths
and weaknesses in other schools
and something that we'll continue to do
is uh help meet the needs and to stay in
touch with you all we will do our best
um we we are available
um to help put information on to the
site about your school so if there's
anyone that needs to be highlighted uh
anything that's going on that's very
important um please please please try to
reach us so we can get that information
out but we will also do the same for you
so i just want to say thank you again
and welcome and thank you for having me
as your library oer curator
and with that
on again on behalf of the hbcus
you are able to upload information share
and we just want to thank again
the hewlett foundation
for supporting this need i have to thank
merlot
for coming and helping us to curate and
mit
kur
team
we want to thank you for allowing us to
share as you all share with us so i'm
going to turn it over to kirk before i
say my final words because together
we can do this
thank you so much robbie i'd like to ask
no this doesn't quite work the same way
as if we're all in the same room
together can we unmute and just applaud
that is so
fantastic
what we've been hearing
yes
i i am so energized by uh by the work
that that you all have been doing and so
it's an honor to um to just reflect for
a moment here before we get into the q a
uh on what we've been doing at mit open
courseware so
for 20 years mit faculty has been
sharing their teaching materials
from a recognition that we need everyone
everywhere working together on global
challenges and we need knowledge and
other tools to do so
now many people come to mit for uh you
know stem
resources right we've we think we've
reached over half a billion people
around the world students teachers
independent learners two-thirds of whom
are coming from outside north america no
question courses like learning to
program or drawing people but people are
also drawn to the incredible breadth and
richness of what we're pulling from
across the mit curriculum in this
one of our most recent publications
black feminist health science studies is
an example
next slide please
so
ocw at mit is publishing from across the
entire curriculum all departments all
programs ranging from introductory
undergraduate to the most advanced
graduate seminars it's really a
tremendous range of topics see here on
the right a couple of other examples in
addition to learning about programming
students at mit are learning about the
social and ethical responsibilities of
computing and we're sharing that with
the world both for learners and also
resources for other teachers to use in
their classroom
we're also sharing for instance videos
in the moment you know down the lower
right
some videos that we shared from
professor amaido for her seminar on
reparations for slavery and colonization
which were posted on our youtube channel
so that
the public could engage live in this as
it was happening in the class and those
comments could be fed back into the
classroom
we have voluntary participation from our
faculty we think about 60 percent uh
have participated
and we're glad to be able to have a team
of people my colleagues on the ocw team
who then do the work of converting those
classroom materials producing the oer
versions to be shared with the world
what's in an mit ocw course it's really
going to vary from class to class
depending on the nature of of the
subject you might find notes you might
find readings
documentation of activities and
assessments you'll also find
increasingly contributions from students
because their voice really matters in
this experience
you'll find more
videos and other rich media and also
interviews with mit faculty about
how and why they teach the way they do
uh to try to create a dialogue with with
other other instructors around the world
who are also
getting into open education last slide
please
so
we are excited later this spring very
soon to be launching next generation ocw
there's a new platform
and it starts with working really well
on phones you know especially for the
many people around the world for whom
their phone is either their primary or
only digital device
better content discovery tools better
search so that people can find what
they're looking for within that amazing
collection but it's not just the
platform and the technology
we're also making new investments in
enhancing our programs to ensure that
the content that we're bringing is
constantly vibrant and current and
up-to-date with what's happening at ocw
and in particular um
uh developing and investing in
collaborations around the open education
ecosystem
in particular those that are centering
equity and creating greater cultural
relevance you know we want to see more
culturally irrelevant oer all the time
and learning how to work together to
create and curate and share this you
know so that we can collectively
continue to take on these pressing
global challenges
so thank you uh
now i'd like to kind of pivot and
open it up in our last few minutes here
for some q a
and i'd like to start by you know
acknowledging just you know robbie uh
appreciation for you know being so sharp
and open open-hearted about the
situation in ukraine and
using our collective uh capacity to
create this new thing
um
what is there any more you'd like to say
about uh about what's led you to
um to open this ukraine project up for
us
um yes kurt um
here this this morning i'm getting up
you know with the jitters ready to
present and then i'm looking at the news
and i'm seeing
and feeling
what's going on
but i'm here drinking coffee and i said
i have to do something we
have to do something
and what can we do
number one we can capture
their culture and start a cultural
curation who knows what's going to
happen with their schools with their
information but right now we can grab it
we can upload it we can start number two
it's about sharing because they're going
to need us
just like those over in haiti and all in
other across the world they need open
education resources they don't have
books
but again
we are collective and i'm so proud of
you all again i know i was off script
but i just thought that kurt there was a
need for us to do something about it and
i've been watching the chat i've been
watching my team upload those urls and
ladies and gentlemen i am proud to let
you know we have over
25 entries for the ukraine collection
this is a blessing but you can see how
with the hbcus we don't compete we
complete each other kurt and we did
something
amazing today with this webinar
absolutely thank you thank you robbie
um
there are a couple questions that we got
from people before the event started
maybe i'll i'll post these
and see
see what ideas people have uh there was
a question from larida about
any specific information about what
what key coursework is most important
right now in the hbcus
what what topics or other
characteristics are you
most focused on right now
and i'm going to let my colleague dr
monique earl lewis jump in because i
think she said it best
well thank you dr melton
we are very concerned about the
assault
on the restrictions of what individuals
are able to learn
these days they're very concerned we're
very concerned about issues of social
justice inclusion and equity
and at morehouse college we are
committed to making sure that we are not
only providing a good education but
developing
leaders for the next generation and
engaging them in the community
so through service learning
culturally relevant pedagogy and i'm
just so pleased with the
ways in which dr melton and jerry hanley
have advanced this when we first became
a partner in 2018
we have to have courses that reflect the
lived experiences of all of our students
and it is not just to benefit students
of color african-american students it's
to benefit our white students our asian
students our led next students who need
to have an inclusive understanding of
the history of this country and of the
world
because we know identity anchors our
understanding
about who we are
and how we are to serve and learn
and so we just look forward to working
with you and other members of the
community through course redesign
engaging technology looking at different
learning modalities
and just bringing our best game to the
table every time
yeah
any other reflections on that topic
anybody else want to jump in
thank you dr earl lewis
um
there was a question we got from uh
uh bridge rajid i think i'm pronouncing
the name right about um how we can
connect students in africa with students
at hbus um and
what we could all be learning and
teaching from each other and you know
maybe start start with africa but just
thinking even more broadly about how oer
spans
geographies and
and different cultures
what experiences might any of you have
have been having to date around spanning
that sort of
different communities
and again kurt that is the reason why we
have dr robert hassell who is going to
jump in because we have a student
initiative again
we concentrate and we should on faculty
but again
our end result is to help students so
we now have a student initiative for oer
and it is spreading spreading not only
between the hbcus but across the world
so i'm going to let
dr hassell jump in and say something
about our student need for open
education resources
i am so excited about the student
education and the resources because our
program here in our initiative our
cultural heritage collections program it
helps our institutions meet the complex
challenge of preserving large and
diverse holdings
of humanities materials for future
generations by supporting them
in their academic programs to help them
uh actually access the benefit of these
research
these research tools and develop unique
strategies and approaches to assist them
in constructing their learning
experience as they matriculate it is so
important that we make students aware of
the endless possibilities not only for
oer to supplement their learning
materials but to enhance their overall
experience in the classroom as well
back to you dr milton
and back to you because i know we're at
the
one minute point
let me just say ladies and gentlemen i
thank you i thank mit i thank the
hewlett foundation and of course merlot
but my hbcu sisters and brothers again
we
were able to bring to you our passion
and our purpose and again yes it's about
the hbcu for this webinar but we're
talking about underserved population
we're talking about access at any time
any place anywhere and i want to thank
all of you who helped contribute to the
ukraine
because now you can leave here and say i
did something
so again we thank you on behalf of hbcus
together
we complete and we definitely share
yeah uh thank you so much ravi that's i
i can't think of uh
anything else to say to take us out that
was uh that was it that was the best uh
just great great appreciation for uh
joining us today and as i said at the
beginning we expect this is the first of
what will be many conversations and um
stay tuned for more of these in the in
the months and years to come
with you all if life is good
life is good
thank you
indeed
you